we've been following all of the
different possible paths forward for
treating the virus we've talked about
antiviral of antivirals we've talked
about antibody treatments we've talked
about the path to a vaccine every time
that this comes up I am careful to say
these are things that are being
considered in early testing we need to
know more we don't have much data yet
I now have for you today and there is a
degree to which we we are sort of on the
on the vanguard here of the treatment of
this we now have promising results from
not one but two of these studies and
we're also learning a lot more about
possible predispositions to getting a
more serious case of the virus we'll
talk about that as well based on blood
type some early data about that so let's
jump right in first of all is a began ok
I told you about a began earlier this
week a began the Japanese antiviral it
was developed by a subsidiary of
Fujifilm if you can believe that back in
2014 the idea was the Japanese
government wanted to have something to
stockpile against a serious flu epidemic
at some point in the future they said
this is as good a time as any to test it
on coronavirus and for a while there was
mere speculation that a began may be
effective we now have a clinical trial
involving 340 Chinese patients and the
results are that Ave again is turning
people negative for the virus after a
median of just four days compared with a
median of 11 days for people who did not
get the drug we've heard it can take
weeks for the body to fight this
naturally median seems to be 11 days
that means half take less than 11 days
half take more than 11 days Avigail
reduces the median to 4 days
lungs x-rays of the lungs improved
within four days in 91% of the people
taking a began compared with just 62%
sort of fighting the virus naturally
without assistance so to speak the
results also say the safety of the drug
in terms of side effect seems high
that's been a concern with a began still
need more information there so that's
all the good news the thing to keep in
mind about the
again trial so far is that they seemed
to really only work well for people with
mild to moderate cases if you have a
case where it's more serious and the
virus is already well established the a
began does not seem to work particularly
well so this could possibly be approved
as a corona virus treatment by May and
that's very interesting second and this
is even more exciting in my mind I told
you about the French biologist and
medical doctor in other words he's an MD
and a biology PhD DDA Rao and he's been
doing some very good small trials he has
now published very good results from a
trial about chloroquine I mentioned
chloroquine as a possible treatment
chloroquine is a really old cheap
anti-malaria drug it's been around since
1934 it's very inexpensive and it has
shown some some promise in treating the
virus dr. Rao found in a small trial
that a 600 milligram per day dose of
hydroxychloroquine which is a version of
the drug reduced the viral load in swab
tests significantly that's great by
itself but now it's getting even more
interesting dr. Rao did an additional
test combining the hydroxychloroquine
dose with a zero Meissen now if as if
throw my sincerity you
that's an antibiotic widely available
sold under the sort of marketing name of
Zithromax
I took it years ago for a sinus
infection it's very commonly taken for a
number of different bacterial infections
combining as if throw Meissen with
chloroquine in dr. Rao's study seems to
be even better now I know what you're
going to say well hold on David the this
is a virus not a bacteria antibiotics
work on bacteria why on earth would a
zero Meissen help azithromycin despite
being an antibiotic has been shown in a
number of peer-reviewed studies google
it they're widely available to have
antiviral effects specifically on
bronchial cells in COPD patients COPD of
course a arrest
taury illness so there's something about
azithromycin that has a mechanism that
works specifically in the lungs this is
very interesting and again all of this
warrants more study but the chloroquine
treatment modalities are being tested in
more and more places there are calls now
that Seattle doctors should start
testing this protocol they have a large
cluster of cases it would provide for
some good data but it could also maybe
help a lot of the patients in that
Seattle cluster so all very interesting
lastly we're now learning about possible
sort of genetic or underlying markers
that might make people more or less
susceptible to the disease it appears
this is again it this is early blood
type might be a factor there's a non
peer-reviewed study from Chinese
researchers on 2,100 patients large
sample size and the idea that they've
found is that if you have blood type-a
you might be at higher risk for kovat 19
compared to all other blood types and
blood type O has lower risk for kovat 19
it's not all or nothing it's a spectrum
it's not been peer reviewed but this is
the type of thing that we're looking at
the next question is if you confirm the
blood type stuff would it allow us to
modify or tailor treatment on the basis
of blood type in some efficacious way
this is all hypothetical at this point
so there's very bad news every day about
the the number of cases and the real
spread of the infection we're also
getting good news every day and we're
learning something new getting a little
bit closer we just need to keep staying
away from each other
while doctors medicine and science do
their work let me know what you think
about this latest news I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show privacy calm is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you $5.00
just for using their free service at
privacy comm slash Pakman privacy's of
service I've been using for a while now
I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of expose
using your real credit card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn from
your checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman